[Music]
we're back chuck
i'm back in your face that's right
that's right
i'm here for you i i am here for you i
appreciate it i like it i like it i like
it on my face
i i my face becomes a lot smarter when
you're in it
[Laughter]
people actually see me that sounds weird
but i think it's a compliment
i don't know what happened your face
looks smarter was never grass tyson in
your face
recently yeah man yeah the world is
changing
everybody's going to electricity if
we're all you know
electrifying cars and everything i'm
totally about it because you're
talking about maybe upgrading the grid
we're talking about electric cars we're
talking about uh
public transportation systems and all of
this supposedly is uh
going to minimize you know our carbon
emissions but here's the thing
yeah electricity what is
i mean aren't we burning fossil fuels to
get
electricity yeah yeah i mean
that's the whole concept of a coal-fired
power plant
yeah that's uh you know i'm just saying
that's a little ugly that's kind of like
i'm not on drugs anymore i used to have
a terrible heroin problem
well what are you doing now morphine you
know
it's like i mean i'm happy for you but
i'd rather you not be on any drugs at
all i don't know if you've ever visited
one of these coal-fired power plants so
they have train tracks
many of them have train tracks that are
right alongside
the power plant and the coal cars drive
each car is filled with coal
like to the brim yeah you know it's
convex on top
and they and they line up against these
huge
bins these vats out there's a surely an
official word for it
and then the coal cars just tip sideways
and all the coal
drops into these hoppers and then they
write themselves back up
and the train goes about its way and
then the coal drops in
it gets pulverized and then
burned instantaneously right you know
you think of charcoal briquettes in your
fire
how come it won't blight and then
finally lights and it stays lit
imagine to take imagine taking that
briquette
and completely pulverizing it into
powder
that's not cool and then inject it into
a furnace it burns instantly yeah and
and super hot too
and super hot exactly so that's what's
going on there why delay
the energy you need in this moment
anyhow so so that's an important
question
what's going on here so last numbers i
looked i think about
about two-thirds of all electrical power
is supplied by
some kind of fossil fuel so if i'm going
to say
let me not drive my car with a
combustion
engine let me plug it in yeah the car
has no emissions
all right he's just running on a battery
but maybe the emissions are just
just someplace else transferred
transferred to the power plant so
uh let me just tell you that the bigger
story
that's going on here okay so
um i'm gonna base some of this on
uh there was a book published back in
2009. the book is called
turning oil into salt it was published
in 2009 let me get their author's name
here ann
corin and gail luft and
let me just share with you some
perspectives there and i've
forever changed for having read their
book
all right uh do you know how much salt
cost
um i think it's a dollar
ten for a giant thing um
okay so you unless it's kosher in which
case it's a little more
unless it's himalayan salt which is a
little bit himalayan which is a little
more and pink and delicious
okay but salty you're not budgeting for
your salt purchase that's right
you're not thinking my gosh we gotta run
out and get salt
nor do you really think or care not to
do your thinking and caring for you but
i'm betting
you're not wondering where your salt
came from unless it says it explicitly
and it's a gourmet fact
it's not a sort of strategic fact you're
not saying if you're not buying some
morton salt and say gee
where did the salt come from you're not
i hope this is fair trade salt
i know you're just not yeah you don't
care you're not
however you go back 150 years you knew
to the penny how much you were paying
for your salt you knew where it was
coming from
you would not be caught without it
because salt was a strategic
commodity it was strategic because
salt was necessary
to survive the winter when you were
storing your
your your your harvested crops so that
you can
not die before your next harvest and
your next access to food
right strategic commodity
what is it called a preservative yeah
i'll preserve it thank you
it was a preservative all right and by
the way
uh grant in this civil war bombed the
southern
supplies of salt as as a strategic
move to try to get them to surrender
sooner
realizing they wouldn't be able to
survive the winter so that's how
important
salt is and in fact if you if you dig up
an early episode of star talk before we
were even video
we had a guy who wrote a whole book on
salt and was one of the more fascinating
episodes ever
of star talk all right and that's when
you learned that the very
word salary comes from the word the
latin
word for salt and in ancient rome they
would pay
soldiers and salt wow what a suck-ass
job it was
to be a roman soldier
oh my god i just spent eight months
out in a battle risking my damn life
fighting these barbarians and now here i
am back and they handed me a bag of salt
literal barbarians they're fighting the
literal barbarians
fighting the literal barbarians and you
paid me in a bag of salt
wait wait till your next paycheck from
star talk before you talk
star talk we pay you in pepper
but don't worry it's full of peppercorns
[Laughter]
so okay so here's the thing so what
happens over the decades
you we oh wait a minute we figure out
how to can food
right canning becomes a way to preserve
it and then it goes well beyond just the
winter
because canning you can can for years uh
what else oh refrigeration once we
electrified cities
even before we electrified cities the
there's the icebox
right once you could refrigerate food
once transportation channels became
efficient
and quicker that reduced the time
between
production of the food and when you
consumed it so all of this
meant that salting foods
was no longer the strategic act
necessary for you to not die
over the winter and so salt just became
just something else
in the grocery list right and not
something you had to have
for your survival you used to be hot
salt
no longer now now it's chipotle
so today
you know where our oil comes from
wars are fought over oil that's right
when the price of oil changes it makes
headlines in the news that's right
because your car runs on oil
and on nothing else so your car has no
choice
you have to buy the product that your
car runs on
and you don't control all the access to
that product that makes it a strategic
asset
right okay so the car
really just needs power
does that power have to come from
gasoline no it can come from some other
source
all right so now suppose i turn my
combustion engine car into an electric
car
so now i'm not putting oil into it
gasoline into it
i take it and i plug it in
chuck when you plug things into the wall
i don't care what a toaster your hair
dryer
whatever do you use a hair dryer
probably not okay
no but i do bathe with a toaster when
things get bad
you've clearly forgotten to plug it in
every time you take a bath with him
so that's what i'm doing wrong that's
what you're doing that's what i'm doing
wrong
they never tell you that but this is it
never bathed with a toaster and you did
the experiment and it was no problem
i don't get the big deal every time i
took a bath the toaster's right here
with we have the cleanest toaster in the
world
so you plug things into the wall
are you asking yourself i wonder what
kind of power this
is are you are you even wondering what
it cost you
it's actually relatively cheap all right
relative i mean compared to other things
you spend money on
it's it's so cheap that if you're
driving away
and you realize guys i left the living
room light on
are you going to stop the car turn
around and go back and turn out tell the
light and then continue to your dinner
no
you just say i'll turn it out when i go
when i get home
right that's how casual we are about
this so you plug it into the wall
you don't know what produced that energy
it could be coal could be
oil it could be a hydro it could be
solar panels it could be nuclear it
could be
tidal you don't know and in fact you
don't care
so if laws change if we run out of oil
if we whatever goes on in the energy
marketplace doesn't have to concern you
the power company says i will now
generate power from wind
from from solar from from hydro by the
way
wind and hydroelectric are both solar
powered
right the sun evaporates ocean water and
that moves on land it comes out as rain
to
some high lake you damn that or a river
you damn that and then you have hydro
power and of course wind powers the
uneven heating of earth's surface
causing wind movement so so solar panels
wind and hydro all solar power
okay so the the electric company if the
price of oil goes high let's swap in
more solar if we outlaw
coal they put bring in hydro by bringing
nuclear
whatever else it is they're not beholden
to oil to create power that comes out of
your wall socket
so if transportation and other things
that use
combustion engines that have a carbon
footprint
if they all plug into the wall you are
planting the seeds of a future
where we have no dependence on oil
whatsoever
all right well i like that and we would
have turned oil
into salt nice uh except i am
not putting oil on my french fries i'm
just saying
no no because you boiled them in oil
exactly
so you're not putting crude oil on your
face i'm just going to say i'm not
putting 10 w40 or
you know or uh oh some some uh
was light sweet crude i'm not i'm not
going light sweet crude on my french
fries
so that's just some of the sort of
backdrop of what's going on
with electricity yeah and one of the
great challenges before we
land this plane here is uh
one great advantage that oil gasoline
has
over these other forms of energy is i
can take a bucket of gas
and i can move it from like here to
there
right and just leave it available to me
when i need it when i need it
okay whereas solar power
you don't there's no unless you stored
that in a battery
right and then carry the battery around
the actual act of
collecting solar power uh is
not the same as storing it and
transporting it
absolutely so if you don't have a way to
store the solar power you only get to
use it while it's coming down while it's
happening
so there's still some challenges you
know plus batteries are like 150 year
old technology
all right and uh
volta was one of the first who sort of
pioneered a good version of a battery
and of course we named volts after him
uh but so there's still
challenges to making this work in its
fullest expression
but i'm just saying the sun is handing
you free energy
every sunny day of the year and to just
let it go to waste
while we are burning fossil fuels
warming the earth is a travesty
and so we need to put our brain power
where in ways
apply our brain power in ways that can
represent us
as good shepherds of our own
civilization so that generations to come
will be proud of what we have done for
them rather than ashamed
yes excellent excellent
we gotta call it quits there chuck all
right all right
so that's uh some earth day uh
perspectives for you
i like it all right all right happy
earth day
happy earth day to everybody and uh
let's let's look forward to the day when
we don't need a freaking earth day
because earth is just fine and our
relationship with it
is stellar see what i did there that
would be great yes and it would be i saw
what you did there
you saw what i did all right there's
been a a star talk explainer video
all about electrical power i'm neil
degrasse tyson as always bidding
to keep looking up
you